a really nice exciting quick cheesecake
served with a strawberry and blueberry
compote biscuits blitz
hot pan sugar we're gonna form a really
nice light golden caramel butter
as the butter dissolves put in your
biscuits
count the biscuits in the caramel they
become really nice and crunchy cool
very calm pot hot pan sugar strawberries
blueberries look what's happening now
got that really nice caramel texture
deglaze the pan for this little baby a
creme de cassis give it a really nice
dark texture cool
cheese cake cream cheese in
vanilla
I see sugar to sweeten up the cream
cheese mix
lemon
cream with
the fold the cream into the cream cheese
fill biscuit crumbs to release the
cutter heat round the outside of the
ring blowtorch
very gently
composite
touch mint that has to be the perfect
quick delicious banana cheesecake been
in a cheesecake with berry compote
done the crispy topping you can see what
that deserves to be a great British
classic
that has to be the perfect strong enough
smoked paprika chicken stroganoff bits
pet silly